dibuja los puntos correspondientes al
máximo mínimo e intersección con la
línea media de la función igual a 2 seno
de un cuarto de x menos 1 tenemos aquí
el lugar para dibujar estos puntos y
vamos a analizar esta función va a tener
su máximo cuando esta parte de aquí
obtenga su máximo y cuando ocurre esto
el valor máximo de la función seno es 1
así que tendremos nuestro punto máximo
siempre que seno de un cuarto de x sea
igual a 1 y que hay del punto mínimo de
la función pues el menor valor de la
función seno es menos uno así que el
mínimo se da cuando esta función seno de
un cuarto de x sea igual a menos uno
cuando alcance este punto tendremos que
multiplicar este 2 x menos 1 y restarle
11 de la misma forma cuando se alcance
el mayor valor se va a multiplicar por 2
y se le va a restar 1 pero ya lo veremos
más adelante y quede la intersección con
la línea media será cuando esta parte
seno de un cuarto de x sea igual a 0
bueno cuando suceden todas estas cosas
para responder lo voy a dibujar un
círculo unitario voy
aquí un par de ejes y recordemos que el
círculo unitario se encuentra en el
origen de mis ejes x y va a tener un
radio de un 1 por lo que aquí va a estar
el punto 1,0 aquí va a estar el punto 0
aquí tenemos menos 10 y finalmente aquí
abajo tenemos cero coma menos 1
comencemos con un ángulo de cero
radiales y si son 0 radiales aquí va a
estar mi ángulo intercepta el círculo en
el punto 10 y recuerden que el valor del
seno evaluado usando la definición de
funciones trigonométricas en el círculo
unitario es el valor de la coordenada y
así que el seno en 0 radiales es 0 y
esto ocurre no sólo con cero radiales
sino también para cualquier múltiplo
entero de dos maceros radiales
aquí agregamos dos pi regresaremos al
mismo punto lo mismo va a suceder para
cuatro pin para ocho etcétera incluso si
restamos dos pies llegaremos a este
punto también así que cuando va a ser
esto cero más un múltiplo entero de dos
pi
escribamos esto acá cuando un cuarto de
equis sea igual a cero más menos 2 por
algún cociente es lo que estamos
diciendo es que si ponemos algo como
esto en la función se no estaremos en
este punto del círculo unitario que
representa cualquier número entero puede
ser 246 pin despejamos x de acá vamos a
multiplicar 4 en ambos lados de la
ecuación x es igual a cero por 4 sigue
siendo 0 más menos 4 por 2 8
porque cuando x es igual a cero más
menos o chopin porque cualquier múltiplo
entero de 8 y toda esta función va a ser
igual a 0
y nuestra y va a ser igual a menos 1
usemos el valor más sencillo de toda
esta expresión que es cuando x igual a 0
si yo tengo que x es igual a cero todo
esto va a ser cero y milles será igual a
menos uno cuando x es cero lleva a ser
igual a menos uno que está justo acá
aquí va a estar la línea media ahora
encontremos el máximo queremos que el
máximo va a ser cuando el seno de un
cuarto de x e igual a uno si yo cambio
mi ángulo y lo incremento de manera que
me quede aquí pi entre dos radiales
voy a interceptar el círculo unitario en
este punto donde se no va a ser igual a
uno así que si no alcanza su mayor valor
cuando tenemos entre dos en el argumento
más menos cualquier múltiplo entero de
dos pies así que para el máximo tenemos
que esta parte de un cuarto de x debe
ser igual a pie entre dos más
- 2 pi por algún número entero bueno
cuál es el valor de x que nos interesa
vamos a despejarlo de nuevo
multiplicamos ambos lados por 4 nos
queda que x es igual 4 pi entre 2 es
igual a 2 pi más menos 2 ping por acá
cual valor de x vamos a usar pues el más
sencillo y de hecho los que tenemos
disponibles en la gráfica no son muchos
aquí tengo 2 pin entonces y x es igual a
2 pin lo puedo graficar lo mismo paso
para graficar la línea media porque de
esos valores que podríamos tomar de 2 x
algo pues el que teníamos era el 0 aquí
en esta gráfica por eso es que lo usamos
acá entonces nuestra x es igual a 2 pi
aquí está nuestra x cuando x es igual a
2 pin nuestro seno de un cuarto de x va
a ser igual a 1 y toda nuestra ecuación
nuestra y va a ser igual a dos por uno
menos uno igual a uno
aquí sigamos la misma lógica para
encontrar el mínimo el mínimo va a ser
cuando mi ángulo lo cambie hacia abajo o
le dé la vuelta hasta este punto
cualquiera de las dos pero bueno me es
más fácil poner un ángulo negativo acá
de manera que voy a interceptar el
círculo unitario en este punto para que
se no sea igual a menos uno aquí estoy
en menos pi entre dos radiales o podría
ser tres pies entre dos que son lo mismo
sustituimos esto acá un cuarto de x debe
ser igual a menos entre dos más menos
dos pin por cualquier entero nuevamente
multiplicamos ambos lados por cuatro y
me va a quedar que x es igual a menos 2
pin más menos 2 pin por acá lo graficó
acá me x es menos dos piques el valor
que me queda más fácil de graficar que
de hecho es el único que tengo
disponible y ahora sí
es menos 2 para todo este seno va a ser
igual a menos uno menos uno por dos va a
ser igual a menos dos le restamos uno a
ese menos dos iba a quedar menos tres
por lo que mi punto mínimo va a quedar
aquí y con esto terminamos aunque
incluso podemos agregar más contexto en
esta gráfica
si yo uno los puntos formando este seno
más o menos así y bueno podría seguir
dibujando más o menos aquí fuera de la
gráfica